I think what people have to adapt to the fact that systems chronically collapse
at every level of severity.
And that's life life.
He is the sequential collapse of systems at each level of resolution.
And so systems last for a while,
great depend on,
but then they,
then they collapse.
And you need to be the sort of thing that can transform itself during a collapse
so that you're there for the next system.
And that's a death and rebirth essentially.
That's your death and rebirth so that the old you that was in the old
environment gets punished out of existence and that hurts like hell and gets you
all depressed and anxious and then you're in a state of crisis and as things
fall apart and then up comes a new you and there's a new environment and away
way you go.
And so people have to be,
people have to be disciplined enough to be part of a system and flexible enough
to transform when the system fails.
And that's basically the two fundamental,
uh,
w adaptive elements that enable success of living.
And people have known that in one form or another for in story form for
thousands of years.